the blue sky. New directions to follow without thinking. Bravo, bravo. We the Kanata killed the
bear and yet it is our friend. The bear chasing the moose turns the earth and gives us day and
night. It also gives us the strength that allows us to hunt it. We owe it much respect and
gratitude. Siberia, the sleeping country, a mysterious region, even today. The forests are
immense. There are unknown animals, ice and snow, enormous rivers, lakes that seem like seas. There
are more than 100 different peoples and each one speaks its own language.
The sleeping country. Why do they call it that?
Siberia for the Tatars means the immense sleeping country. It is said that only birds
when they migrate know where it ends. Master, who discovered Siberia?
Discovered. Discovered. Man has lived in Siberia for tens of thousands of years.
It was the Abirans who crossed the Bering Strait more than 20,000 years ago and first
set foot in America. In the 13th century, Heinrich Hisken invaded Russia and it took three centuries
for it to be liberated. In Moscow in 1689, Tsar Peter the Great was the very lord of the country.
He wanted to make his kingdom a modern power and traveled to educate himself. Friends, this is the
last straw. The Tsar only listens to the foreigners around him and he ignores us, the usual nobles,
and asks us to shave our beards. What? The beard. His majesty, the Tsar. Gentlemen, beards are out
of place in a modern country. You must shave them. But, your majesty, we have always worn
beards. It is a tradition that dates back to ancient times. Exactly. What interests us is
the future? Come, barber, you do not refuse to obey your emperor. No, no, no. We will obey,
sir. Beards are not for civilized men. Of course. Yes, we have to be modern. If you could see
yourself. And do you think you don't look ridiculous? Look at yourself. Peter first
ordered the construction of Saint Petersburg, which was the capital of the north. Let's see
this, my dear Kirikov. Saint Petersburg faces the Baltic Sea in Europe, and Archangels to the north,
but its port is frozen half the year. It is also close to the North Sea, but the Turks control the
strait that leads to the Mediterranean. And here is Siberia, but I don't even know how far it goes.
We should send an expedition. I already have the man, Your Majesty, a Danish excellent sailor and
cartographer who serves in our navy. His name is Vitus Baring. Okay, but he must think that we don't
know where we are sending him and what we are going to discover. It has to be secret. Do you
understand? Of course, your majesty. It will be an expedition of explorers. Yes, but the natives
we discover will have to pay taxes. By the way, what about your beard? Hey, I paid the tax to wear
it, sir. My beard is not a symbol of tradition, but of wisdom. That is what I expect. Captain Vitus
beer, your majesty, and Lieutenant Alexis Cherikov, who will accompany him. Two trustworthy men.
Baron, I appoint you captain first rank of the Imperial Navy. You will go to eastern Siberia,
build two ships and follow the coast to see if Siberia is connected to America.
Then we will see. It took Bering two years to cross Russia and reach the port of Okosk.
Now I don't think it will take us long to reach the port of Okosk, right, Pittus?
Tell me, friends, in which direction is Okosk?
Okosk, but you are already in Okosk.
There are no materials, no men, no forges, no glue, no houses to sleep in.
But how are we going to build ships and with what?
With that wood.
And if we can't nail the planks, we will glue and sew them.
Glue and sew them, but what do you say?
Let's get to work.
Come with me, Alexis.
Let's look for ropes.
Look, there are the ropes.
You think that's gonna float on the water?
We'll float.
We'll put on double the planks.
Alexis, look at the provisions and the equipment
The sails
You didn't forget the sails?
Of course not, Captain
Come on, let's unfurl them
Very good, Ketro
Loaded
What?
In there
Goodbye
Here he built another ship in six months
The Gabriel, bigger and sturdier
And set off north
America must be around there
Yes, but how far away?
Maybe 30 kilometers, maybe hundreds
You can't see anything in this fog
Oh, there, Vitus
Look, Iceaver
All the way to port. All the way to yoke. I said to port, you idiot, you're gonna sink the ship.
Hold on, the iceaver is moving. Everybody to bab. You, you and you, jump on the iceaver quickly.
Put a pike there. Look how slow they are. Useless. They're useless. What's wrong?
Save. It's about time. We must have passed the strait without seeing it. How long could it be?
Do you have any idea, Alexis? No, but we could go and see it. No, it's not too dangerous. Winter
is coming. We could get stuck in. The ice. Turn around. You failed the mission. You squandered
the Imperial Navy's money for nothing. You're not even Russian, Captain Baring. You couldn't
have betrayed us. Are you crazy? What are you saying? We reached the Arctic Ocean and proved
that Siberia is not connected to America. These men did an extraordinary job. They did what Peter
the Great asked them to do before his death and I will pass it on to his successor, Empress Anna.
I thank you very much, gentlemen.
Your Majesty, Peter the Great managed to make Russia a powerful nation and we must continue his work.
These explorers did a magnificent job, Your Highness, and the empire could extend to America.
Do you understand, Your Majesty?
You were right, Kirikov. Send an expedition. You have carte blanche. Go.
At your command, Your Majesty, my friends, it will be the most important expedition in history.
We will prepare it with Memo. The Russian Empire was immense, but what lay beyond the ocean?
There were other lands that no one had colonized. That's what Beryl should discover.
Everything is ready, Lieutenant. Yes, everything except the experts. They've been preparing for
it for two years. I'm fed up and I'm going to tell them. The Academy of Sciences.
Thank you. Gentlemen, the expedition is ready and we're leaving tomorrow.
No, it's not possible. We're not ready. And we're in no hurry.
Well, I am and I'm tired of waiting. I'm leaving tomorrow. If you like, you can meet me in Yakutas.
If not, we'll do without you. Oh, how impudent. Who do you think you are? Not even Russian.
Because you're German and I'm French. Do you have anything against the Dutch? Or the English?
Answer. Correctly. You'll take care of the scientists. Go ahead. See you. Soon.
An important expedition will set sail in September 1733. More than 2,000 men and women,
sailors and soldiers, farmers, cooks, ranchers, paradarros, blacksmiths, set out on an adventure
that would last 10 years. As for the scholars of the academy, we are not ready yet. Not yet.
Come back another day. We are almost ready. We are ready. You can take inventory. But tell me,
how many of you are there? 600. 600. Are there 600 scientists? Of course not. But we need our
staff. And what kind of staff? Well, our secretaries, draftsmen, cooks, servants, sommeliers,
housekeepers, tailors and librarians, the personal guard, the shoemakers, the interpreters,
they speak Latin and classical Greek. Latin and classical Greek. May the Lord have mercy on us.
And here are the telescopes, the barometers, the magnets, the clocks, the cartographic maps,
the work library. And that, that's Bordeaux wine to accompany the meet. Chablis is for the fish,
Sotel for desserts, champagne for the parties. And that's really it. Along the way Bering sent
several expeditions to the polar seas. And three years after his departure he reached Yakutas.
Alexis, finally. And where are the scientists? They're coming. Well, to work. Look, we have to
do everything. We have neither lodging nor provisions. It's been four years since Bering
left and he hasn't even reached the ocean. His expedition costs a fortune. And what does it
bring us? We have to. Trust him. The expedition is very difficult. Good morning, gentlemen. My
name is George Steeler. I'm a naturalist and I know about medicine. I have to meet up with
Bering's expedition at all costs. It's an extraordinary expedition, without precedent.
I can't miss it, but the expedition is far, very far away. Well, I want to go. That would be very
dangerous. Listen, gentlemen, I assure you that I will be very useful. Just give me the authorization,
whatever you want, but at the risk of losing my life, young man. Captain Baron is here. No,
he just left the Yakutska to go to Yakutas. Is Captain Baron here? No, he just left the Yakutas
to go to Okosk. They had to Ketro. These cookies should last us more than a year. Take them to
Kanchaska, aboard the... What's the name of that ship? The Hope. Aboard the Hope. All starboard.
starboard, captain. But. Obey orders. Ketrov hasn't arrived yet. Anyway, we're heading for
Petropolo. Kanchaska. I'm looking for Captain Baron. He left Okos for Kanchaska. It. Can't be.
If you want to find him, come with me aboard the Hope. In that case, in the state I'm in,
I'll embark on the Hope. The coast of Kanchaska is not far. E-Baron. Over there towards the east
coast. I'll take command of the San Pedro, Alexis. You'll take the San Pablo. We'll take the.
Captain. Oh, Captain Baron. My name is George Steeler. I'm a naturalist. I know a lot about
medicine. I've been chasing you for four years. The Admiralty gave me permission to accompany you.
I don't see anything. Here's the Admiralty seal signed by Ivan Kirilov. I'll believe you.
Time's coming. Our doctor is sick. We're underway. Mr. Ketrov, you too this way.
Heading east-northwest to America. At your service, Captain. We've lost them.
we'll see them later in America. Where are we, Captain? I don't see anything. We're approaching
the shores of America. Look, Steeler, it's America. I wonder if anyone lives here. I'll go and see.
And so, George Steeler was the first European to set foot in Alaska. No one has fled. But look,
this. It's an American bird. These birds don't exist in Siberia. It's America, no doubt about
it. That bird is American. And I've also seen plants that aren't found in Siberia. We have
to explore the interior. It's not too risky. We have no food and we're a long way from Kamchatka.
We must return. Many men are sick. Myself, scurvy. I have herbs that can cure him for a while.
The wind is from the west. We must take advantage of it. It's going to be a long one. We have no
water left. We are near an island. We must land. We must find a quiet bay. Okay. That idiot has
wrecked the last longboat. We must take a chance. Take me to the fire. I know I don't have much
left. Listen to me, young friend. We must dismantle the San Pedro and build a smaller ship. It's your
only hope. Yes, Captain, but rest a little. There are eyes, thousands of eyes. They're gone. It's
the island of the foxes. It's not the island of Beren. The captain is dead. Now we must protect
ourselves from the winter. To begin with, we are going hunting. Yeah, what a curious ship. I wonder
who they could be. Alexis, are you alive? Diller and Captain Beren died on an island that I named
after him. Bering performed a superhuman feat. He traveled incredible distances in terrible
conditions. Along the way, he built villages and forges. He introduced agriculture and livestock
farming, but above all he discovered Alaska, which became a Russian colony. But Master,
Alaska is not Russian, it is American. No. In effect, the Americans bought it 100 years later
and found gold and oil. It was a great business that brought them many benefits, but that is
another story. Let's explore the corners of our world that is constantly spinning. To find
routes to trace, always taking a step further, never giving up for the good of humanity. Ah,